loin des boîtiers d'un serpent non non
[Musique]
normal et mathieu alors c'est très
simple première épreuve la première
épreuve
elle est là je vous le dis dehors il ya
kho lanta qui reprend derrière ces
coupes elle il y a un gros ver blanc à
manger et soul autres coupes l'ol il y à
un délicieux verre c'est un bonbon voilà
un verre voilà un bonbon à la fraise
alors allez-y honneur à norman il
choisit je kiffe ce jeu c'est vraiment
super ouais t'as carrière commence il
est vivant le vert je sais pas moi c'est
pas moi qui fais les coupes et les voilà
bah vous allez au défi manger le montre
aussi ses colonnades mains n'avoir
jamais allé manger plein c'est pas
possible
inquiétez pas ça ça mais c'est rien et
vous allez voir quand vous avez croqué
il va lâcher comme un petit truc
impossible ça où tout est possible mais
je sais rien il est très vite très vite
derrière une des boîtes il y à un
serpent oh non non non faut arrêter la
série trauma que je veux je peux
vraiment des fire non mais vous
inquiétez pas venez de mon côté donc
dans une des boîtes qui vient c'est
repos et on en est dans l'autre il y à
un bois ac reçoit en plastique d'accord
non est jeune il va alors ça non
choisissez c'est bon non mais juste vous
touchez un peu le serpent pour la faire
aller roanne etc les boîtes atteinte en
attaque à droite zaidi cela allez vite
quel bois je l'espérais
quel boîtier à les matches - celle-là on
connaissait la bad et la [ __ ] je ne la
mets ici mais je sais et
c'est le vrai ou pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc normal enfin tout normalement
molsheim phobie totale avec logiciel
chez un peuple attendait regarde c'est
peut-être pas sur un qu'il y soit allé y
regarder il est là il est vraiment
dégueulasse que j'ai rien à sa garde et
c'est du serpent d'eau douce c'est
magnifique fête hussards sur la tête sur
la tête
bon allez sur la cgem ya il y a deux
personnes il faut trouver le noir il y a
deux personnes il y en a ils ces deux
personnes
baru ces deux personnes il y en a un qui
est champion de karaté et l'autre il n'a
jamais fait de karaté de sa vie d'accord
l'un s'appelle brian et l'autre
s'appelle thibault elle s'appelle brian
landes youssou ndour vous devez appeler
au hasard brian ou thibault et de voix
vous mettre un coup de pied de karaté
sénat à brian [ __ ]
alors brian juste petite question est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait si vous avez
déjà fait du karaté
oui j'ai déjà fait auparavant quand
j'étais petit et vous jamais jamais ces
tombes adenyo alors house à quelque
chose quand même
oui merci à nesle coussin règne dans les
rangs webb à la voile a battu vous allez
vous mettre la sève la fin ça transforme
et et mettez-vous là je vais tomber sur
le site aurait fait gaffe quand même
voilà il va tous nous tuer un boulot un
web j'adore tout on continue je kif
attend un petit peu un dernier un
dernier alors foiré mais bon dieu merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps j'avais eu un centre
d'emerson
[Musique]